You talk about playing the
game, quote unquote, to win,
but what about people that play the
game to win for themselves and how do I
defeat there? That's a good,
good question. And it hit me.
Yeah, when I saw that question. Ooh,
that's a good point. And that's a good,
there's a very important distinction
there because I'm always saying play the
game. Yeah. Or, Hey, you can't
play the game. You got up,
you got to build the
relationships with the boss.
You've got to learn what they like.
And you kind of told the party line,
you kind of do the little things.
You got to support the,
the corporate headquarters or
the boss or the man, right?
Or whatever entity is
up in that ivory tower.
I want you to play the game,
get them on your side.
And the reason I saved to do those things
is that so you can get more controls
so that people ask your opinion so that
you get listened to so that perhaps you
get promoted,
which is good.
But the reason you're
doing all those things,
the reason that you're playing the game
is to help your team accomplish the
mission.
That's what you are trying to do is to
help your team accomplish the mission.
Now the, the other side of that
is what this question is about.
People that are playing
the game for personal gain,
they, they play the game so that they can
get listened to so they can drive their
personal agenda so they so vague can get
promoted and they want to get promoted
so that they can abuse their power.
And maybe that abuse of power is just,
is just working less. Maybe it's
making other people do the crap jobs,
whatever the,
whatever the case may be.
But they've got an agenda and they're
going to try and get promoted so they can
take care of themselves.
And that is not why I
tell you to play the game.
And that's not why I played the game.
And I definitely played the
game and I played to win,
but I played because I wanted my my
squad or my platoon or my task unit or my
training command to be able to
better accomplish our mission.
That's why I played the game.
Now
there is a secondary benefit of playing
the game and that is that you could
possibly get promoted earlier.
You could get praise from the boss that
looks good on your record and and all
those things can happen when
you're playing the game.
But that's just like collateral
sort of fringe benefits.
But that's not why
you're playing the game.
You play the game to help the
team win and when the team wins,
you win,
which also makes the team win again.
So it's like a positive cycle because
you start developing a good reputation.
Now you get more leeway from the Boston
and more leeway you get from the boss.
The more you have the ability to
make maneuvers on the battlefield,
the more you can maneuver
on the battlefield, the
more offensive you can be,
the more offensive you can be,
the more you win,
and then you get more ability to move
more because your boss has given you even
more room to maneuver. So it's a, it's
a cycle. It's a good positive cycle.
Now when you have someone that's on
the team that's playing the game for
themselves, first of all, no
one likes that person, right?
Everyone can see that person. Yeah. No
one likes them and there's, believe me,
the military,
the military has unbelievable people
that play the game for the best possible
reasons to help their platoon and
help the mission and help us succeed.
There's also plenty of people
in the military and in every,
every different line vinyl work.
There's plenty of people that play the
game because they want to. They want them.
They were looking out for themselves.
Yeah. Looking out for number one right?
Isn't that the expression they're
looking out for? Number one,
there's plenty of people and I dealt
with people like that all that time
and what did I do?
I used it to my advantage and I'll tell
you what I would get in their head and
what I would do is I would make them think
that the best way for them to win for
themselves personally
was for the team to win.
That I would get that into their head
because they'll tell a lot of times they
miss that point.
They're looking out for themselves,
they're not worried about the team.
And I would get them thinking that
they're going to look the best if the team
wins. Hey, if you really
want to look good,
the best way you can get promoted
as if we look good. You know,
if the team does great, if you get
us the gear, we want the equipment,
we want the training that we need,
that's the best way you're going to look
awesome cause we're going to succeed
more and that's going to
make you look good. And I'm,
of course I'm going to be more tactful
than, I'm not saying it like that,
but I'm saying it right.
Right.
Get get those word and getting
them to get the messaging is there.
You want me to be saying
things like, hey, you know,
our boss doesn't like our boss doesn't
like leaders that complain. Right.
[inaudible] you can tell the boss
he doesn't like complainer's.
You know what I mean? Little things
like that, right? Yeah. Hey, the boss,
the boss likes to hear the truth
about stuff he wants to know.
You know what I mean? Little
things like that and you know,
here's the thing, that person, that
person might get the promotion.
Okay.
Because what you've done is you've
helped them act correctly actually,
and there's a chance,
a decent chance,
a good chance even that they carry
that forward. They realize that, hey,
the best way to play the
game is to help the team.
And the best way to look good is to help.
That is to make the team good
and succeed at the mission.
Hmm.
And it's really one of the classic cases.
Then we'll know we'll get
into ownership a little bit,
but if something goes wrong,
right,
the person that's looking out for
themselves blames everyone else.
And so that's a challenge, right?
Because once you start blaming,
once that ball starts blaming everyone,
then the whole team starts blaming each
other. So how do you fix that? Well, it's,
we've talked about this a million
times. You, you step up and say, hey,
you don't bosses my fault and lost
cause that's right. It's your fault.
And there's a,
there's a good chance that they
recognize how positive that is.
And it may take a while and it may never
happen because some people are just
savages, right? Some people are just
complete. They only care about themselves.
They only care about the next promotion
and getting the next award and getting
the next bit of recognition.
There's people like that,
there's, they're horrible,
they're horrible, they exist. But
they're pretty small. Most people,
if they see, hey this, this
is working for this guy,
it can work for me too.
And that starts to spread.
And the other thing that happens
I think is if someone's obese,
just a flagrant self promoter,
that you might get them one promotion
because you were there to kind of make
them look good, but the next time
around they're going to get seen.
They're going to get found out,
they're gonna.
People are gonna realize what kind
of person they are and that's,
that's where it catches up with them.
So you keep playing the game,
you keep, you keep working hard,
don't worry about them and actually
do your best to help them out.
The person that's like self promoting,
They're the boss. Make them look good.
I always want to make my boss look good.
Yup. It's going to help you in the long
run. It hurts sometimes it's hard to do.
Sometimes our ego gets in the way.
Sometimes God put that ego in check
because what's more important?
Because if you're my boss Echo and you're
doing this just to make yourself look
good,
if I then undermine you will.
And now we don't accomplish
the mission as well.
I'm actually a bad person because I didn't
do my best to accomplish the mission.
Right. We didn't look good. Yeah.
I'm not worried about how we look,
but we failed in our mission.
Well,
we didn't do our mission to
the best of our ability. So No,
I'm not going to let that happen.
You want to look great. Cool.
I want to make you look great because I
want us to look great doing our mission
because that's what's important to me.
And if so some of the collateral damage
of that is that you look great even
though you're a jerk
and I get you promoted,
that's okay because eventually you're
going to get found out or you're going to
learn to be a better person and to
support the team and that's how you got
promoted and you're gonna realize
that and you'll become a good leader.
Yeah. Yeah, I agree with that one.
Like I always have where people
can see that too. You know,
they can see like if your boss is like
a self promoter or whatever and you have
it in your head.
I understand.
I understand this cause I did it in
a situation where I'm like, shoot,
I kind of feel inside,
like I don't want to like go
make an effort to make them
look good kind of thing.
Cause it's like he doesn't deserve
it and a thing and what? Like what?
I'm going to make them look good and now
everyone's going to think that he looks
good kind of thing. But then when you
really think about it another not,
they see that. Yeah, you're right.
And the goes though for you. Like
if you, if you're like to, you know,
if you're just focusing on
the positive stuff, you know,
you know how like what do they say if
you don't have anything nice to say,
don't say it at all. If you're really
doing that, like people notice that too.
They'll be like, man that
guy is like really positive
focusing on this, you know,
kind of thing. Like people see it and
this doesn't mean you're just Mr Positive,
sugarcoating everything. And I don't know,
it's not, we're to talking about that,
but you are not focusing on the negative.
Instead of saying,
oh, we're horrible at this.
You say, you know what,
we've got some deficiencies here. Here's
what I'm gonna do to fix them. Yeah. Yeah.
How simple is that? Better? Yeah, no,
the point is people they see, they see,
don't think that, you know, like
you're going to help, you know,
make this guy look good
in there and just get it.
They're going to not see it and then
they're just going to fall further.
He is trick or something bad. They see
that most of the time. Most of the time.
That example that you said about, um,
uh, playing to their ego or whatever,
where you're like, hey, you should,
you're going to look really good if
you've ever seen the movie Milana,
I saw three minutes on it. Oh, see,
there you go. She does a, so the guy,
the main guy name the demigod who's
name is Molly and played by the Rock,
by the way, 20 Johnson.
Great movie by the way. Um,
she does him like that. She's like, Hey,
let's, they got to go do this mission,
you know, for restore the heart, you
know, whenever it's a long story, but,
and he's like, you know, whatever
reluctant. And he's like, she's like, hey,
you'll be a hero again. And he's like,
I'm already a hero. She's like, well,
no, not for a while. You know,
you haven't done anything lately,
but if you do this and you'll be
the hero to everyone. And Yeah. Any,
and of course he does it of course. But
yeah, man, it's good example. It works.
There it is. Proof on, on Maulana.